welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your house definition aka the youtuber
that's universally considered a [ __ ]
this video were breaking down the crazy
story that's shaking up Hollywood right
now that is a lot of cinema chains are
refusing to show Universal films in the
wake of comments made by the chief
executive of the company throughout this
video we're going to be going through
the news and discussing why I actually
think that this is a smart move by the
theaters before we get into it make sure
you subscribe to the channel for videos
like this every day and please hit the
thumbs up button if you agree and
dislike if you don't
so the original comment from NBC
Universal came in the wake of trolls
world tour Jeff Schell chief executive
of the company said the following when
discussing its release the results for
trolls will tour have exceeded our
expectations and demonstrated the
viability of P VOD as soon as theaters
reopened we expect to release movies on
both formats do the accent so basically
this means that Universal will be
putting their films out in this cinema
and on video on demand at the same time
so you can buy the film and watch it at
home early it's a thing that we've saw a
lot of Studios doing in the wake of the
pandemic with movies like bloodshot The
Invisible Man and The Hunt all being
available to watch from home Universal
are now viewing it as a D way to release
their films and it went down worse than
a Big Mac at a vegan festival AMC fired
back releasing a statement stating the
following AMC will no longer play any
universal movies in any of our theaters
in the United States Europe or the
Middle East it also extends to any movie
maker who unilaterally abandons current
windowing practices absent good-faith
negotiations between us look at you look
look at you using those fancy words so
massive warning to the rest of the
industry to not even consider this
strategy if they want their films to
receive at the at Racal release AMC
owned Odeon one of the biggest cinema
chains in the UK and they announced that
they would not be showing the films over
here regal cinemas in the US joined the
boycott and Cineworld are now part of it
too so everyone universally
hate Universal all of a sudden and they
didn't even block their Halloween skills
plot leaked video worldwide because it
was true
cheap shots coming from the heavy
spoilers show - I don't like use either
anyway there's basically two sides of
the argument one that think this is a
natural evolution of how things will go
and either side that thing's universal
are about to ruin themselves by doing
this now personally I tend to side with
the latter but I'm gonna explain why
universals upcoming releases on Jurassic
world 3 Halloween kills fast 9 and some
other crap
probably trolls will - a 4 or something
these are all expected to make a lot of
money however they will also potentially
lose a lot if they're not released
through theaters now cinema chains are
dying I don't think there's any argument
there streaming has changed the
landscape of film and now it's easier to
watch things at home you don't have to
drive out into the night sit in a room
of recycled thoughts and genuinely it's
probably a more pleasant experience at
home where you can pause the film or set
on your phone for 45 minutes I didn't
buy this 70 inch TV for nothing hi there
that's the old model and I do think that
in the future cinemas will adapt and
change in order to make an experience
once more we're saying that cinemas are
dying because we only have the model
that's existed for almost 100 years to
judge your own in future the way cinemas
run may change to where it's like a
restaurant or a bar and you can CIN have
a meal whilst you chill out and watch
the thumb some select cinemas have
already started to do this and I can see
being a model that's widely adapted in
the future so I think cinemas will stay
relevant as the model isn't too rigid
where it won't adapt now why I think
this is a bad idea for Universal is
because they think that because trolls
was successful that everything will be
but let's look at some of the potential
reasons as to why it was firstly we are
in the middle of a pandemic and a lot of
parents are stuck at home with their
kids every day they have to constantly
find something to distract the spawn of
their loins the Beast that currently
cries out for them and the night and
therefore I can see people happily
throwing down $20 to get the new trolls
movie it's not a lot it keeps them happy
and they can sit in the room drinking
themself
to death constantly checking their phone
to see if it's all over yet
so using trolls as a way to base your
future business model around seems a bit
strange to me there's not enough
evidence there to support that this is a
strategy that will continue to succeed
because it's unlikely that we'll be in
lockdown for the rest of time another
aspect is that piracy will skyrocket if
all Universal films are released on VOD
I know that in the case of the Invisible
Man when it was released on VOD I I mean
my uncle well not really my uncle or my
mates uncle well not really made more of
an acquaintance anyway he watched it for
free about eight times he simply
couldn't do this in the past but due to
screen recording technology if things
are uploaded to VOD you can quite easily
record them in 4k and upload them to
wherever I also think VOD sort of
devalues the movie just a bit it's the
modern day straight to DVD and I think
that if things are constantly released
on VOD people will just stop watching
them think about all the shows that get
released to streaming that just fall by
the wayside now imagine that but with
films and you have to pay for them on
top of the subscription service that you
already pay for yeah I think I would
just give it a Miss to be honest I think
I'd watch a couple of titles but on the
whole I doubt I'd fork out that much
money every time whereas with cinemas I
have an unlimited pass where I pay 18
pound a month and can go as many times
as I want on top of that if you look at
the box-office trends Universal don't
bring that much in in the grand scheme
of things Disney actually now bring in
75 percent of the earnings year by year
and though initially people thought that
theaters were saying goodbye to their
revenue stream when he consider all the
other studios like Warner Brothers Sony
Lionsgate a 24 and so on that make up
the other 25% Universal probably isn't
that big of a chunk in the grand scheme
of things I think going forward in 25
years time anyway most theaters will be
Disney theaters anyway because they're
buying up absolutely everything right
now
you're next Sony basically what the
cinema is doing is that it's actually
saying we don't need you good luck
so what Universal have done is cut off a
massive part of their distribution chain
now
things will only be released either on
VOD or in smaller cinema chains that
still wish to show their movies AMC is
massive in the US as is Odeon and cine
world over here
so that's cutting off a lot of places
that your films can be shown I think
this may also scare other Studios and
stop them from potentially doing the
same thing in the long run it will cut
people off from your movie and sure VOD
is cool and a good way to watch movies
but it also takes away from the prestige
of your film it opens it up to piracy
and the main thing that holds piracy
back right now is that a lot of films
are captured on cams so people don't
want to watch them because they're so
low quality if they have access to
higher-quality copies they will no
longer have this as an attractor and
therefore will watch them so whilst I
may be in the minority I'm siding with
the cinemas on this one I think that
this has been done for a specific reason
though and that is because the cinemas
wanted meeting with the studio obviously
they've worked together in the past and
I can see them actually coming to a
compromise where they may get
exclusivity for the cinema for a certain
amount of time and then VOD will follow
shortly after that would be the
direction that I could see things going
in now since all this happened
Universal have come out and responded to
the controversy and said the following
we would only look beyond cinema
premieres when it makes sense we
absolutely believe in the theatrical
experience and have made no statement to
the contrary as we stated earlier going
forward we expect to release future
films directly to theaters as well as on
PV o D when that distribution outlet
makes sense a goal in releasing trolls
world tour on PV o D was to deliver
entertainment to people who are
sheltering at home while movie theaters
and other forms of outside entertainment
are unavailable so they pretty much
backpedaled on it and I think now that
they're likely working overtime to go
through how to handle a situation I
think it just works out the best for
both parties to keep things the way they
are the model has been in place for
decades for a reason and it just feels
like both sides of something to lose if
they decide to go this route personally
though I think that it would be a bigger
loss for Universal over the cinemas and
that's just looking at it from the
that data and basically be hating
Universal I'm just kidding Universal I
forgive you
now obviously I'd loved hear your
thoughts on this and if you agree with
me or if you think that it's a smart
move by the studio comment below and let
me know and if you enjoyed this video
then please give it a thumbs up and make
sure you check out our breakdown of all
the latest updates on the Batman we go
over a new Matt Reeves interview Robert
Pattinson straining and what the penguin
and Catwoman could look like so yeah
definitely check that out if you want to
support the channel from as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below
we massively appreciate you and there's
a thank you you get access to content
early if you want to come chat yourself
at the show either follow us at
definition whitey or click the discord
link in the description below every
month we give away free movies to be
able to subscribe to the channel and
this month you can win the Marvel phase
3 part 1 box set and all you have to do
is comment on a video and make sure you
submit notifications on the more videos
you comment on the more you have a
chance of winning so make sure you get
involved the winners gonna be chosen at
random on the 15th of May and the cell
be shipped out from then to ever gets
the prize it's the best of luck that
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe huge thank you
for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best now see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you